i want to go to roy boyd right now the
goliad county texas sheriff and sheriff
always good to have you but
this rage being expressed by
you know those in martha's vineyard and
in some of these other areas where
migrants are landing i didn't see this
when
guys like you were dealing with this on
your own from anyone outside of texas at
least politicians outside of texas um
but it does seem odd when it's in their
neck of the woods that you get this
response what do you make of it
well you're absolutely right and that's
the genius and what governor abbott has
done is on the other side of the
spectrum the liberal side wanted to
pretend like nothing was going on and
everything was fine and dandy what what
the governor did is the governor opened
this back up into the national scene and
caused them to have to react to it from
a political and a public standpoint so
it just goes back to uh you know the
deliberate mind of of the governor and
what he's done to try to bring this this
problem back into the spotlight while it
was being ignored you know i i
distilling fernandez sheriff a state
representative representing the martha's
vineyard area uh but he had said
something interesting to me uh not to me
but but made a statement these
immigrants but first of all they're
illegal immigrants these immigrants were
not met with chaos they were met with
compassion we're a community in a nation
that is stronger be because of
immigrants but again
by just calling them immigrants and not
illegal at the face of it uh
that
gets maybe to the core of the problem no
one's distinguishing and a lot of these
sanctuary cities
they're not distinguishing yet they
don't want those immigrants and that's
what makes this kind of weird
well they're all real good about
embracing the theory of what they what
they espouse but they're not really good
at dealing with it from from the actual
perspective of seeing it on a day-to-day
basis and you know they talk about all
this and the spokeswoman for the white
house talks about compassion and all
this stuff but in reality the inhumane
side it comes from the fact that the
administration has provided a completely
open border and we have we have turned
over our responsibility and
of our border over to the cartels and
the mexican government and they're
enslaving these people because when
these people get off these buses they're
not just free to go wherever they want
live their life they still low money to
the cartels and most of these people are
going to have to go off to where it was
they were assigned and they're going to
have to go into indentured servitude
we're importing a peon class and putting
them into slavery right here in the
united states obviously the
administration and their talking heads
took a really good point from joseph
goebbels who said that
even a lie becomes the truth if you tell
it enough times and that seems to be
what they're doing right now yeah i
don't know got that far sure but you did
match an interesting point and there's a
notion that they're immigrants and again
and again i've heard it from new york
mayor eric adams or we've heard it from
the washington mayor the chicago mayor
uh that that this is a bad treat and
again and again they say of immigrants
and our welcoming nature so if they
don't recognize these uh
migrants as anything less
than illegal uh and they're seeing them
as illegal their lines the problem right
that that tells you they don't see it as
a problem two million migrants trying to
get into this country that they don't
see that as an issue they're not illegal
they're immigrants and we have to treat
all immigrants equally those who go the
legal process and those in this case who
don't that does not hint of any progress
on this
well there's no desire for progress
there's just desire to continue on with
the problem we have if they wanted
progress this week when i drove all the
way out from nogales back to texas i
wouldn't have driven through a bunch of
border patrol checkpoints that are
closed unmanned there's nobody there out
of all the i went over 950 miles the
other day driving home from nogales and
i found one checkpoint that was manned
and there was only one person in the
checkpoint and he was just waving people
through because what's he gonna do with
a line of a thousand cars down the
highway what's the one border patrol
agent they're gonna do he's just gonna
stand in his booth and flag everybody
through
the the border is completely open and
we've seen that firsthand and it
continues to this day
sheriff it is amazing thank you very
very much chef roy boyd of the goliad
county texas sheriff hi everyone i'm
brian kilmeade i want you to do me a
favor i want you to click to subscribe
to the fox news youtube page this is the
only way that i know for sure that
you're not going to miss any great
commentary any great news bites any
great interviews coming your way on fox
you can get it all here on youtube so
subscribe right now